Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in Zmed we concluded last
night verses number 15 and 16. Now verse
number 17 is connected to the two
previous verses. It builds on that.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"Indeed, we have sent to you all a
messenger
as
to you all a messenger as a witness
upon you, just as we have sent to
Pharaoh, a messenger."
And Pharaoh proceeded to disobey the
messenger.
And so we took him with or we overtook
him or we engulfed him with a very
heavy and grave punishment for his
disobedience.
This is exactly
the meaning of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's statement. Listen
to what your prophet says. He said,
[Silence]
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said every single person from my the
here is
meaning anyone
whom the prophet is sent to
whether they accept Islam or they reject
it they are considered generally
speaking of his nation
meaning they are his responsibility
he is their messenger. They are his
nation.
So everyone that you've ever met,
everyone that I've ever met, all of us
going back to the time of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam, anyone
who existed from the moment he received
to the last human being taking his
drawing his final breath. All of these
people are considered what?
Sai wasallam they're considered to be of
his nation. He says
everyone of my nation will enter
paradise except for those who refuse to
go.
That's very bizarre thing. Who would
refuse to go to paradise?
So the companions
they understood that this is very
strange. So they said
who who would refuse to go to paradise
he says
he said whoever obeys me will enter
paradise and whoever disobys me he has
refused to go.
He has refused to go.
Now this disobedience here
is either general complete disobedience
or partial disobedience.
A Muslim may have partial disobedience.
Meaning they know what's expected of
them but they fall short.
But essential disobedience,
complete and utter disobedience is the
disobedience that is discussed here in
this verse.
Pharaoh
disobeyed that messenger.
That disobedience means entirely he
refused to obey him in belief, in
speech, in action. He he refused him
entirely. And so this is a type of
disbelief.
This is considered to be disbelief
that comes as a result of utter defiance
of utter defiance. Kind of the
disobedience of
thatl refused and was arrogant and he
was then of the disbelievers.
So after having said this, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
following verse which is built on these
two verses
for
[Silence]
Allah says, "So
how will you then protect yourselves
if you if you disbelieve
this statement?" So fell here
means if that is the case,
if the case is that we sent to Pharaoh a
messenger and he disobeyed the messenger
and we've sent now to you all a
messenger and you've disobeyed the
messenger,
then how is it do you plan to protect
and shield yourselves from the wrath of
a day that will render even infants
white-haired from its horrors.
What is a tawa in the Arabic language?
Huh?
Protection.
A little bit, but you could do a little
better.
Huh?
a shield maybe. Right. A tawa
comes from al what is al
is a shield.
[Silence]
in the Arabic language comes from the
root word
which is a shield to something that a
person uses they put between themselves
and something that harms them. This is
called a
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
in that of his great blessings
he has given us and imparted upon us the
knowledge to be able to design for
ourselves clothing that will protect us
and shield us from the heat and clothing
that will shield us from the violence of
one another. Right? armor.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala uses this word
throughout the Quran.
And that is he says
that the guide that the Quran is the
epitome of guidance for those who are
people who seek to shield themselves.
What does that mean? people that seek to
shield themselves, meaning shield
themselves from the punishment of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Allah says,
Allah says, "Shield yourselves from the
fire."
And Allah teaches us to make the dua. So
shield us from the fire. What is a tawa?
A tawa is a state of being, right? It's
an action.
Let me ask you a question.
What is who is the only one that can
save you from Allah?
Huh?
Allah himself. Anyone else?
It is only Allah that can save you from
himself.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"Flee all of you and run to Allah."
Meaning, "Run from Allah to Allah."
Listen to what the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam says in his dua.
Oh Allah, I seek refuge in your pleasure
from your anger.
And I seek refuge in your pardon, from
your from your retribution.
And I seek refuge in you, from you.
There is no protection nor any place of
salvation
that will save someone from you except
with you. So the only one that can
protect you from Allah is Allah. The
only one that can protect you from the
fire is Allah. How do we earn Allah's
protection?
Tell me.
Huh? Well, that's the word that we're
trying to define. Use a different word.
[Arabic recitation]
the only way he's going. That's the only
way you earn his protection. Correct?
So, the scholars have defined
in the Quran. Listen to their
definition.
Listen
to this definition. They say tawa is
that a person
obtain a shield
for himself from the punishment of Allah
by fulfilling his commandments and
refraining from his prohibitions. The
more intense your obedience is, the more
stout and robust that shield will be
from Allah's punishment. And the more
flimsy
that a person's obedience is of Allah,
the more flimsy their shield from
Allah's from Allah's
punishment.
And so when Allah says,
does it just mean fear? Often it's it's
translated as that. But that translation
is a bit deficient, isn't it?
Because
him.
[Silence]
So when we say fear of Allah,
fear Allah,
this isn't really a translation. This
isn't really a tap. This is one of the
one of the necessary components of tawa
because you would only seek to shield
yourself from something if you're afraid
of it.
Therefore,
they call it fear. But really, it's much
more it's much more broad than that,
fear.
So a tawa really is obedience of Allah
that results in being shielded from
Allah's punishment being delivered
protected from Allah's punishment. So
here
the word tawa
is being used in a linguistic sense
meaning how then do you all plan on
shielding yourselves from Allah's
punishment if you disbelieve in him on a
day that is so horrific so terrifying
so encompassing in its horrors that even
infants
will be rendered gray-haired from the
horrors of that day. What is your plan?
How do you plan to do that? The only one
that can protect you from that is Allah.
And you've disbelieved in him.
Therefore, what is your plan in
protecting yourself?
Even infants
who can't comprehend anything will
comprehend enough of the horrors of the
day of judgment that their hair will
turn white.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
that
subhanahua
[Silence]
He's saying that it is a day when even
infants their hair their hair will turn
white from the the fear that will engulf
the hearts of man on the day of
judgment. Even an infant an infant
doesn't comprehend really fear, does it?
You guys have kids. You had to teach
your kids that fire was hot, didn't you?
You had to teach them to not walk on
balconies without railings. You had to
teach them things that they were not
naturally afraid of, but they will be
naturally afraid of the day of judgment.
So here Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala poses
a rhetorical question.
He says, "How do you plan to protect
yourselves? How do you plan to shield
yourselves from the horrors of a day
that only Allah can save you from and
you've disbelieved in him?"
And so this is
the question that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala posits to every human being,
every one of us. Can you imagine a day
that is so horrific that infant's hair
will turn white from grief and fear? Do
you think on that day you can turn to
your buddy and say, "Give me one hassa.
Just give me one." Okay, you're going to
make it. I'm not going to make it. I
need one hass to just tip my scales and
make it to paradise. Can you please
spare one hass? Do you think they're
going to give you that one hass?
Huh?
infants hair are turning white from the
fear of that day. Where is this hass
this magic hassa going to come from? Or
if you say to your best friend, your
confidant, the person who would die for
you in this life, in the next life,
listen, my scales of sin are a little
bit too heavy. If I just take off one
sin,
one sin, I will make it out of the
hellfire. You are clearly going to make
it. Please just take this one sin off my
hands. Are they going to take that off
your hands? Absolutely not. Nobody wants
that. That is the day when only good
deeds are going to have any worth and
only sins are going to be truly feared.
the day of judgment.
And so a person can accumulate wealth in
this world. A person can,
you know, sit back and fantasize about
how they've got it all worked out. But
truly,
if that is the fear that takes people's
hearts on the day of judgment,
none of us is safe.
The only safety we can have is in Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And for this reason, if a person
understands this deeply,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has promised
that one of the seven types of people
that Allah will
give shade to on the day of judgment
when there's no shade but his. One of
them is
A man who thinks or remembers Allah
in private and his eyes swell with
tears. Why? Because every one of those
tears is a prayer.
A prayer only to Allah
saying, "Ya Allah, please I have no one
but you." Now, if that is the person's
heart, then Allah will protect him.
But if the person's heart is looking to
a prophet to protect him, looking to a
an angel to protect him, looking to the
grave of a saint to protect him, or I'm
going to get on our prophet Muhammad's
good side and he's going to protect me
on the day of judgment, you've got a
very big problem waiting for you. Why?
Because even our prophet Muhammad
sallallah.aii wasallam, what did he say
to his daughter, most beloved? You're
not He's not going to love you more than
he loves Abu Bakr. He's not going to
love you more than he loves. He's not
going to love you or me more than he
loves Fatima. What did he say to
He said, "Oh Fatima, daughter of
[Arabic recitation]
ask of my wealth. Whatever you want,
I'll give it to you. if I can, but I
can't help you with Allah. That's
something you have to do. You have to
earn that from Allah. You have to ask
that from Allah.
And so Allah doesn't give us details.
These are some of the first details of
the day of judgment that the prophet
Muhammad is receiving. Remember this is
the third chapter. Remember that the
most eloquent of speakers, the most
eloquent of speech is speech which
creates in the listener what first?
We mentioned it last night.
[Arabic recitation]
It is speech that cur creates curiosity
first and then fills in the blanks here
and there. And that's why in some
verses, in some chapters, Allah speaks
about the fire. And in others, he speaks
about the fear. And in others, he speaks
about the depths of the hellfire. In
others, he speaks about the attitude of
the people of hell. Filling in those
that curiosity slowly slowly until a
person has an overwhelming
an overwhelming depiction of paradise
and hell. and the hereafter
in his mind. So, of course, now a
person's reaction, a sane man's reaction
to such a description, a day when
infants will be rendered white-haired,
he says, what a sane man's reaction
would be, I choose Allah. Tell me, tell
me how. Tell me how.
So what do I do? How do I get how do I
earn Allah's protection? He says
he says this Quran is merely a what
these verses
is are merely a reminder. So we are now
directed back to the Quran which we will
tie these verses back to this one
[Arabic recitation]
in the coming gatherings inshallah
you might figure that out?
Start. Okay.